[Music]
the presidential commission on the
supreme court which held its final
meeting in early december 2021 was
designed to provide analysis of possible
reforms of the court aei's adam white
was one of the commissioners the
commission did not take a position on
one proposal favored by many
progressives expanding the court's
membership what do americans think
americans opposed franklin roosevelt's
court packing plan and polls today show
more opposition than support the
responses vary a september monmouth
university poll found 58 opposed to
expanding the court with 36 percent in
favor the july marquette law school poll
also found more opposition than support
april posed by morning consult and ipsos
reuters found more opposition than
support 46 to 26 in the former and 42 to
38 percent in the latter in each case
democrats were more in favor of
expansion than republicans the reuters
ipsos poll also found that 63 percent
supported term or age limits for the
justices while 22 percent were opposed
do you think the supreme court should be
reformed and if so how let us know in
our poll also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from aei